alors on en vient à critique qui compte
beaucoup pour vous il compte beaucoup
dans la l'histoire du cinéma et
s'appelle andré bazin et il vous a
accepté de parler d'un livre qui vient
de sortir qui sont vraiment kyi et d'un
américain qui s'appelle d'aude léandro
avec une préface de françois truffaut
nex de jean charles tacchella et c'est
publié conjointement par les cahiers du
cinéma la cinémathèque française
éditions de l'étoile sous la direction
de jean narboni l'ouvragé a été traduit
de l'américain par serge grunberg bon
alors tout ça étant dit il faut dire qu
andré bazin c'était plus pour vous qu'un
grand critique plus qu'un ami c'était
presque un père parce qu'il a joué un
rôle assez considérable mais certains
moments dans votre vie oui oui enfin
c'était le plus grand critique de cinéma
de la libération jusqu'au bout dit
d'ailleurs c'est plus agressif un
écrivain un écrivain de cinéma c'est
aussi davantage qu'un critique parce
qu'il a été un animateur voyez à
l'époque de la libération seul moyen de
voir des bons films de voir c'était des
ciné-clubs bon il était un animateur
ciné-club il présentait le film il a
animé le débat
il a créé l'ailé jeunesse
cinématographique un peu sur le modèle
des jeunesses musicales de france
il a été de toutes les aventures de
l'écran français de la revue esprit de
la première revue du cinéma
et puis surtout des cahiers du cinéma
donc il a eu une influence
il a cessé ses dents ça qu'il est
davantage celle ci qui parce que ma il
assure le public nous sommes et
créatures la ville a une influence sur
les metteurs en scène de la génération
précédente sur les metteurs en scène qui
sont venus après lui c'est à dire ceux
de la nouvelle vague et l' influence
aussi sur public parce qu'il a formé le
goût du public
à l'époque à la libération dans il le
remarquer dans un de ses premiers
articles
les critiques ne parlait jamais de la
lumière de décor on parlait que de
l'histoire
bon on identifiait d'ailleurs pas le
film au metteur en scène il a beaucoup
contribué aussi à identifier les flux
monétaires en scène et à faire une
critique plus exigeantes
pendant un an à la libération il
présentait par exemple tout une ou deux
fois par semaine le jour se lève dans
différents coins de la périphérie en
démontant le film en expliquant comment
cet effet en demandant aux gens de
regarder le décor les producteurs du
film lui avait prêté du matériel donc il
expliqué le rôle de chacun voilà c'est
en ça qu'il était davantage qu'un
critique son rôle n'était pas de dire
c'est bon ou c'est mauvais il voulait
savoir de quoi cet effet comment cet
effet à tel point que des metteurs en
scène comme renoir ou bunuel rossellini
je les ai vus avec lui presque comme des
élèves vous voyez avec un professeur
bien que la différence d'âge ils étaient
plus jeunes que parce que il est mort
très jeune à 40 ans il aurait 65 ans
aujourd'hui et il était jean renoir en
particulier plus âgés que lui est venue
elle aussi mais ils étaient
impressionnés par basa impressionné et
renoir a dit souhaiter jambes et de
modifier des projets en pensant à bazas
par son intelligence
je vous trouve un peu hypocrite parce
que alors alors tout le monde sait que
lorsqu'il était critique aux cahiers du
cinéma
douze équipes féroce absolument fait
rose hill enfoncer les gens à siala l'a
donc fait rationner d'accord mais féroce
et vous avez vraiment et puis dix ans
vous ne trouverez jamais dans son oeuvre
d'azun un article féroce et papiers
d'humeur dans l'esprit peut se résumer
par chouette c'est mauvais oui mais pas
ce que je souhaite c'est mauvais je
trouve que c'est un état d'esprit
affreux quand même qui est complètement
qui n'est pas généreux probablement
j'étais pas à critiquer le bazin était
un homme généreux c'est pour ça que je
laime aussi peut-être que je envier
cette qualité que j'aurais voulu avoir
avec les temps sont les lèvres des pas
réussi à acquérir ou que j'ai pas un peu
pris par les d'ailleurs il racontait
enfin mais oui il raconte qu'ils vous
disent est coûteuse on avait des
polémiques m'enfin c'est quand même lui
qui a allumé premier article qui m'a
publié dans les cahiers du cinéma qui
m'a beaucoup encouragé beaucoup bd oui
bon alors cessé c'est une biographie ce
qui est curieux c'est que ce soit un
américain qui fasse la sexy de l'avis de
parce que c'est presque toujours comme
ça les français n'aiment pas écrire des
biographies parce que le système
français repose sur le système
universitaire qui encourage la thèse
donc on fait des tests on ne fait pas de
biographie et puis la biographie souvent
suppose aussi un espèce un peu un
investissement de la part d'éditeurs est
ce qu'on ne fait pas non plus beaucoup
en france
donc vous avez vu ici je crois que vous
avez présenté la biographie de camus par
un américain se livre sur l'esprit
gauche souffre assez remarquable sur
l'esprit nrs voir lothmann c'était
américain aussi en amérique comme disait
il ya trois ans le pdi qui est fait par
un américain on me disait en amérique si
henri langlois avec les américains il
aurait déjà trois livres sur lui voyez
les français n'ont pas été fichus et on
vient de faire une biographie de
l'emploi c'est un américain qu'il est
pourquoi dites vous dans votre préface
andré bazin nous manquent pas parce que
c'est le cinéma qu'il espérait le cinéma
qu'il voulait le cinéma qu'il appelait
de ses voeux est arrivé malheureusement
après sa mort vous voyez il est mort six
mois avant hiroshima mon amour il était
un grand ami de renée il est mort avant
nos premiers films il est mort a revu
vos premiers films non il a lu le
scénario de 400 comme il n'a pas vu le
film il est mort le deuxième jour de
tournage de 11 novembre 58 donc il est
mort juste six mois avant l'éclosion de
de ce qu'on appelait la nouvelle bague
est en tout cas de films plus personnels
de films comme il le souhaitait et des
films qui aurait ressemblé à des
premiers romans c'était toujours ce
qu'on demandait à ce moment là et je
crois qu'il leur est a sous sa pensée sa
réflexion enfin nous aurait été très
très utile parce que il nous arrive
souvent de tâtonner